what's up everyone Persia here and today
we're talking legends of runeterra not
only is this game a unique take on the
card game genre but the art and soul of
each and every card will remind you why
you've grown to love these champions in
the first place
legends of runeterra has masterfully
translated some of our favourite
champions from League of Legends to fit
seamlessly into the card game genre
without losing the charm and utility of
their original form let's go ahead and
take a look at some of GameSpot's
favorite legends of runeterra cards you
either love them or you hate him either
way he's ready for duty Teemo in lor is
as cute and dangerous as ever as he's
rightfully equipped with his poison puff
caps much like in league of legends
you're gonna want to watch your step or
draw in this case because with every
nexus strike
teemo plants 5 pus caps randomly in your
deck at 15 caps total he levels up in
doubles at count with every nexus trait
which means if he's left unattended you
could possibly end up with hundreds of
shrooms ready to pop every time you draw
a card being elusive makes that slightly
easier but he's relatively squishy so if
you're the one in control a Teemo he'll
need an extra bit of attention to keep
him alive successfully leveling up not
only gives you an adorable animation but
a much more fitting splash art of him
running from a massive explosion of puff
caps don't let it be you
one of my favorite things about lor is
seeing how champions have been adapted
for card games without losing their
flavors who we know them to be Brom is a
great example of that he's still a
phenomenal body shield with an
immaculate mustache and this time around
the power of the Poros is stronger than
ever you're gonna want to take him out
sooner rather than later however that's
gonna be easier said than done
since he regenerates his health after
every round and has challenger equipped
so he's able to choose who he's taking
damage from after blocking 10 damage
total we get to see that award-winning
smile and he calls in a mighty poro
whenever he survives damage after you're
back before you know it you could be
facing Brom and his poro army who are
ready to overwhelm you
Tryndamere is another dangerous champion
but for the complete opposite reason
Brom is the set of blocking Tryndamere
will gladly welcome all the damage that
comes his way
just like in League of Legends when you
think you're gonna kill him you face the
wrath of his undying rage and he becomes
a whole new problem we already know chin
demure is a threat but he levels up upon
death which will make you think twice
about how and when you want to make your
moves his leveled up splash art totally
encapsulate his rage and rightfully
earned him the fearsome buff leaving
only enemies with an attack higher than
three able to take him on that mixed
with overwhelm and a stronger tankier
form makes him as terrifying as ever
last but certainly not least will
actually be two cards Lucian and Cinna
are not only perfect for each other but
they're also perfect and lor as they
bring a bit of their backstory with them
as a working mechanic as a champion card
lucian is able to level up but only does
so when Cinna dies in front of him which
turns him into a deadly force who's out
for revenge his legal legends passive
comes to light as he gains double attack
and the first time any Ally dies he
gains rally which allows you to attack
again even if it's not your turn Cinna
is not a champion card herself but she
does gain a buff when she sees Lucien
die too
seeing Lucian and Cinna fighting
side-by-side in Santa's splash art is
too cool especially when you know their
backstory but what's really impactful is
the intensity in Lucian's eyes when he
levels up you can feel the pain behind
them after losing her and his
determination to take out everyone who's
had a hand in it that wraps it up for
our favorite cards but any card could
have easily made this list since they're
all just that good whether it be the art
the utility or the intricate translation
of our favorite champs there is always
something new to find in legends of
runeterra if you like League of Legends
and it's universe but want a change of
pace then maybe it's time to give
legends of your tarot track thanks for
watching